and our first guest is Natalie Bennett
of the Green Party
okay let's get to our first question
which comes from Sam Duffy Sam which is
also historic part of British history
and identity will benefit the nation
well I think's very much for that
question and I want to sort of clarify
something that wasn't being reported
widely around on the papers you I was
talking about people were asked if we
didn't have the money anymore we're with
the Queen Liv and I wanted to make what
was a very serious and important point
with that which is that I don't think
anybody anyone in Britain at all should
fear being homeless but in terms of
Green Party policy on the Constitution
the fact is we've got just over there in
Westminster an institution of parliament
that hasn't been reformed in nearly 100
years years the last big change was
women getting the vote and we're nearly
coming up to a century of that so what
the Green Party believes is we need to
start again what we're actually calling
for is a people's constitutional
convention there could be some people in
this room who could actually be members
of a constitutional convention starting
with a blank sheet of paper saying that
we're how do we want to govern ourselves
for the 21st century now in the Green
Party we've got lots of ideas about what
that should look like
we certainly don't believe there should
be an elected House of Lords we
certainly think that we need
proportional representation in our
elections and we don't think that the
hereditary principle should have any
place in our government but what we're
saying is rather than us saying what
should happen we're saying that the
people should decide yeah I suppose
though it does and I said I'm not quite
sure would you keep the Monica Queen
right now well what we're saying is we
would give it we're calling for a
people's constitutional convention start
from scratch say we think we need a new
constitutional settlement for Britain
you know all the issues we've seen round
got a devolution around you there's been
lots of change but Westminster hasn't
moved their whole main structures
haven't moved let's start again ask the
people and say what should it look like
so we have views but we're saying that
people should decide okay well let's
move on to the next question it's Adam
Adam Ward hi and so in the first past
the post electoral system there are many
marginal seats where your party is
unlikely to win and I'd be interested to
know in those seats and which parties do
you advise your supporters to vote for I
would say vote green we're going to be
standing in as many seat yes he probably
got very surprised by that I can
understand that but the thing is with
being in Britain trained by the first
past the post electoral system to
actually vote very often for the
personal party we dislike the second
most to stop the people we really hate
getting in and that's actually given us
the kind of politics that we have now
what we've done is people we've seen
particularly the two largest parties
focus all of their policies on the swing
voters in the swing seats they've
ignored they call vote they've ignored
you know the whole issue of what's best
for the country but thought what do we
say to get those swing voters and if
voters keep voting the same way you'll
keep getting the same kind of politics
so what we really need to do is actually
you what I would urge everyone to do
obviously I'd like you to vote green but
what I would like you to do is vote for
the person part of your policies in your
constituency who best represents your
views those policies that really feel
like that's the person who I'd like to
represent me and if we do that and
there's a real possibility that what we
could see in this election is the Scots
showed us the way in the referendum an
85 percent turnout young people voting
in almost the same proportion as the
over-60s
when usually receive 60 65 percent
turnout and young people in much lower
proportions if people did that people
went out and voted vote what they
believe in whatever that is we could
actually have a peaceful political
revolution so it's actually in all of
your hands as voters to deliver that is
that question answered are you thinking
of tactical voting as well and I'm doing
a blog following 15
marginal constituencies across the
country I hope we're not ignoring anyone
that I was just interested because we
meet a lot of an candidates particularly
like green ones and seats where they may
have be unlikely to win and I'd just be
interested to know I was interested to
hear your thoughts on what they they
should be well I think you know in the
take-home message that I want to get in
now because it's so important is for
everybody but particularly young people
to make sure that they're registered to
vote you know the system has changed
secretly people at universities who used
to be registered automatically aren't
being registered anymore you just need
to Google register to vote you'll find
it there there's a bit of a barrier and
that if you'd register online you need
your National Insurance number but you
know you can get back from the student
loan company if you're at university but
you know please do register to vote and
have your say and your one of the things
I say is you I'd like you to vote green
I'd like you to vote for someone you
believe in but if there's no one on the
ballot paper who you think you know
represent your views still go to the
polling station and if you want to write
a rude word on the ballot paper because
if you don't vote if you just don't turn
up you don't register you're counted
with the I'm happy enough with how
things are part of a group and I don't
think most people actually are tempted
to ask which read where that is but
let's move on let's move on to a
question from social media which has
come in so this has come from I'm not
discourse polls how can you consider
making membership of aq al-qaeda and is
so-called Islamic states legal well
thank you for this Twitter user for
giving me the chance to clarify this
obviously is and Al Qaeda a hideous
terrorist organizations that advocate
and support violence we know if you are
involved in them support them in any way
then you are participating in inciting
violence that's a crime
rightly entirely rightly and should be
pursued to the full extent of the law
okay anyone want to follow up on that
from the floor no okay
well we'll move on to Molly Malone with
respect the fact for the fact that we're
all growing up in a competitive job
market to what extent do you think that
I'm paid into
jep's justifiable I think unpaid
internships
they're absolutely unjustifiable and the
Green Party calls for them to be banned
what we've actually seen is a situation
where what used to be first jobs the job
you'd expect to go into and get paid a
reasonable salary for after you left
university or after you left school or
college that's now become an unpaid
internship and that both is deeply
unfair in terms of and you find this
particularly in jobs that have
particularly sought after I used to be a
journalist and you know I used to be the
editor of The Guardian weekly and I get
people ringing me up begging to come and
work to it for me for nothing and that's
just not right and the only people who
can afford to do that are those who've
got some sort of financial support
behind them so it just perpetuates
inequality in our society and I think
you know what we've got to do is draw a
real line between volunteering and you
we all we all know what it what about a
volunteering role and it into an unpaid
internship looks like sometimes it's
hard to draw a line but if you're going
to go and walk the dogs down at the
local dog dogs home on a Sunday that's
volunteering absolutely fine
brilliant want to encourage it
everywhere but you know if you're going
and work working for six months for a
multinational company have to go in at
certain hours expect to do nothing
expect to not be paid anything but
you're doing a heap of work that is
unfair and unreasonable and simply
shouldn't happen how does that sound to
you Molly with the state if the job
market at the moment how easy do you
think it would be to ban them and
completely but I think what we have to
do is simply say anew we want to enforce
at the moment we have a minimum wage
that's not enforced if you have
effectively a contract with a company
that says you're going to turn up 9:00
to 5:00 for six months that's a job and
it should be covered under minimum wage
legislation and of course you might know
that we think the met current minimum
wage is really inadequate and we think
that the minimum wage should be a living
wage as a basic standard so if you work
full-time you should earn enough money
to live on we're gonna spread this out
can we you I know you've all got strong
opinions about this internships work
experience who wants to come in on on
this he wants to come in on whether
internships should be banned
at least a minimum wage should be
enforced the other thing I want to say
is I mean some people actually do end up
doing unpaid internships because it's a
way to get their foot through the door
is the way to get experienced a way to
you know hopefully get a job which
usually isn't a guarantee so I think
maybe what we should be looking at is
the job market much widely for young
people who are graduating and unable to
find jobs or then forced to go do
internships yeah I think that's an
important point I will in no way blame
anyone who takes one of these because
you're doing what you have to do the
problem is the companies the
organizations that are making this
happen and you I was talking about the
minimum wage being a living wage but we
also need to go much broader than that I
talk about jobs that you can build a
life on and that means not zero hours
contracts not being forced to work
part-time when you want to work
full-time and it needs some sense of
security and some sense that you might
be able to progress because one of the
other problems that we haven't generally
as a society talked about much it's the
fact that the minimum wage has all too
often become pretty well where most of
the wages are at you get whole
organizations where lots of people are
not you know the supervisor is on 50 P
an hour more than everyone else is on
the minimum wage and people can't build
a life can't build a career on that so
just the reason why we're having this
type of debate an issue that's not in
the political sphere generally but very
keenly felt by young people so forth
questions now join Laurie and I think
joy and so my question to you is do you
think that politics should be taught in
schools so that young people actually
know what the point of voting is and
maybe it would encourage them to vote
more do you think it's something that
should be inbuilt in the education
system I think very much so and I was
actually down at Bournemouth University
a few couple years ago now and they've
done one of the undergraduates have done
a study and quite a lot of people
speaking to her sin they didn't vote
because they really didn't know what
would happen when you went into the
polling booth you didn't know what it
would look like they hadn't been much
rehearsal you know much the sense of
what knowing what you were going into
and I think you know we need education
about politics in schools but what we
also need is actually democracy in
schools we actually need you
school councils school organizations
that have some kind of real say I'm not
just talking about what color the jumper
is or something like that but you that
have a real say and if your start from a
very early age at school start voting
then you can move on from there but I
think I mean it also raises a much
broader point about the whole education
system and at the moment really what
we've got is a system that very much is
treating all of you all the people
younger than you like they're in a
sausage machine rammed through exam
after exam after exam in a very narrow
range of subjects things like cultural
subjects being valued as they should be
and also we're not getting what I call
education for life things like education
about personal finance about first aid
about sex and relationship education
about the whole sort of things that can
actually make sure you can go out into
the world ready to face whatever the
world is going to throw at you as for
going to go into a polling station and
voting and for the ballot paper for
blind and partially sighted people it's
quite difficult because we have to trust
someone to go and write the right cross
on our paper when our paper and what do
you think that we could do to make it
more accessible for people like for
people like myself or joy to actually go
and be independent about our vote and
not have to trust someone else to do it
for us I don't know about the exact
technical arrangements but what we need
is a principle that says everyone's able
to exercise exercise they vote
themselves and I actually I think a
council election down in Lewisham
a couple years ago it was in a mountable
cabin and they were steps up to it and
there was no disabled access access for
wheelchairs and that's just absolutely
unacceptable and we have to be saying
that democracy is for everyone
accessible to everybody
thank you I think we're going to go to
hope with the fifth question
certain measures which you put in place
to help solve the housing crisis our
generation are facing with more and more
young people moving back home even when
there is the introduction of the housing
schemes ok well this I think is that is
the one issue that people come to me
most often about and I know people
involved with the Green Party who say
you know I've got a job but I can still
only get a share room in London and what
we have to do the sort of underlying
principle is we have to get away from
the idea of housing as a financial asset
and get back to them being homes so one
of the key so that is build much more
council housing you know genuine the
affordable housing not what's so-called
affordable housing in London which is 85
80 percent of market rents but what we
want to do also is put a cap on private
rents give tenants security of tenure
which also means they can't be thrown
out in revenge evictions if you know
they ask the landlord to fix the boiler
or the landlord says I'll go away I'll
find someone who doesn't care if you
don't have been working for that boiler
and we also want to end want to want to
make sure that we protect the council
housing that we have now so that means
ending right to buy is that convincing
you yeah it is well has it was a big
issue I'm going to spread this out and
some of you must have some some thoughts
on this gentleman here
do we have a we'll just wait for the
microphone to come over I see one here
you go when you step up hi I'm a
graduate
Lynde the big problem I've had is that
I've just got a job in the city ops near
to me which is about 20 miles away I'm
having to travel in every single day to
get there my job doesn't pay enough to
get me an accommodate the house there I
can't look at renting because I have
already money to pay off so I'm in this
perpetual loop and I'm also a computer
science graduate and there's the problem
with that of I live in the middle of
nowhere so I can't move to any of the
bigger cities to get a job in the field
that I'm actually qualified in how would
you see about helping without ok well
there's there's a whole lot in there and
you know like low low wages housing
costs to some extent I've already
covered so I think one thing that I
really like to focus on there is
transport and the cost of transport and
you know we have some of the most
expensive train fares in Western Europe
we have a system where the railways are
run for shareholders not for passengers
so one of the things the green party
what we want to do is bring the railways
back into public hands and Caroline
Lucas the green MP has a bill before
Parliament to do just that now and what
we've also announced is funding that
would see a train and bus fares cut by
10% in the next parliament what we're
going to do is take the money that the
government is planning to spend on
building new roads and we actually know
that new roads a lot of these were
schemes that were abandoned decades ago
and they just completely generate new
traffic and move traffic jams around so
instead of building those new roads we
put the money into public transport and
one of the big things that we're you
know I find going up and down the
country people talk to me about again
and again is local buses and we've seen
local bus services just absolutely
slashed and the funding for those
disappear and you know I quite often go
into towns and cities and people say to
me during the day they meet me and they
say oh I'd love to come to your public
meeting in the evening but the last bus
is 5:30 to my village and
one day from where I live I had to take
a train down the day beforehand
in order to do that Sasson issue that's
quite close to me as well yeah and I
think you 2/3 of job seekers don't have
access to a car and some of them just
can't even physically get to job
interviews to people feel that not
having cars transporting issues sea
transport doesn't rate as a very high
issue nationally but just for you
anything more housing house building
there's derelict houses in the UK and
has been programs recently to fix up the
houses with unemployed people
what would the green party do to use
these houses in a more efficient way
than just to leave them derelict that's
something that they will actually be
making an announcement on soon in terms
of the details of how we want to do that
but I think one of the things that's
really worth focusing on is where a lot
of those homes are and a lot of them are
in the north and some parts of the
Midlands and the situation is that
because of our imbalance Regional
Development money resources people have
all been focused on London and so
consequently what we've seen is you know
those good houses I've walked down the
streets on the Wirral with perfectly
good houses boarded up and so we need to
rip one of the things we need to do is
rebalance regional development so people
can actually live and have jobs like you
you know if you had a job near your home
or even we're able to work from home if
we leave the infrastructure for that and
one of the things that we're opposed to
is the proposed HS 2 to the proposed
high-speed rail way because we think
that will actually focus money and
resources and people even more on London
and not what we need to do is invest in
infrastructure and transport across the
regions across the north the sort of bus
service as I was talking about all kinds
of different investment do chip in if
you've disagree with any of that now's
your chance forever hold your silence
yes go just on high-speed - and do not
think that actually getting rid of
high-speed - you're actually neglecting
the regions that are distant away from
London and that won't grow because you
don't have a fast connection there well
I think the thing is what we need to do
is develop strong regional economies a
situation where money goes round and
round in local economies
where instead of you know if you're a
business person and you need a new
service you don't race down to London
and talk to someone in one of the
offices somewhere around here but maybe
it's easier you can perhaps across the
pin lines and go to someone in a city or
town actually much closer get the
service there and then that gives you it
gives you the job closer to home
potentially you creates it creates more
balanced economy that work vice-versa
for people going from London out to a
different place to get a service there
and then coming back do you not think
that works like that as well well I
think one of the things is I saw some
figures from Atrus to saying seventy
percent of the 72 percent of the
journeys would be people coming into
London that's their own figures and I
think you what we've got is a very
powerful pull effect from London and we
really need to work to balance that up
and that means you're if you and get
investment east-west rail lines local
buses local trains and also make sure we
get a more balanced economy you get away
from the focus on finance and services
we really need to get back to making
more things to growing more of our own
food to having you know an economy that
creates all kind of different sorts of
jobs built around particularly small
businesses cooperatives rather than
necessarily big business multinationals
I think you've got a question with the
last Jewish population and as I'm sure
you'll be aware there's been a rise in
anti-semitism lately so what I wanted to
ask is that bearing in mind people like
Maureen Lipman recently say she'd
consider leaving Europe due to the rise
in anti-semitism I sort of the news of
an exodus of Jews from Europe after the
Paris attacks for example
what would you do is leader to ensure
that Jews feel safe and welcomed in the
UK I think you know what we have kicked
me after the Paris attacks and that fora
a real sense of fear in many different
communities and you know I think what we
need to do is lots of work to bring
communities together to help them to
understand each other to speak together
communities across intergenerational
work all of those kind of things we
actually have to make sure that people
feel included not pushed out and people
feel safe and that that's a balance to
be struck but we need we need to do both
of those things and you know what we
need to do is is really understand
want to come back I appreciate the
sentiment of that and I agree with the
idea of that but sort of what would you
actually do to make sure that happens
because it's quite sort of I mean it's
quite a vague answer well I think it's I
mean what we need to do is fund those
kind of projects get people together
make sure yeah and it's it's a broad
thing but we need to make sure people
don't feel excluded from our society and
that people we've got to balance
obviously basic safety kind of
proportions but we also need to need to
make sure people feel included educated
supported and that's really the key
anyone else want to come in on issues of
race religious hello so I've been in
Wales for the past week working with an
organization called women making a
difference and a lot of women that I
spoke to mention that the you know
United Kingdom flag it doesn't represent
any part of Wales but it does I learned
it does a bit Scotland would you look
also if you become leader would you also
look at you know making sure that the
whole of the UK feel part of UK because
I just say I think it is very focused on
not just London but just I I think I
mean what you're raising is an issue
much broader than the flag and I was
actually up in Carlisle when there was
lots of talks about the English
Parliament and English votes for English
laws and people in Carlisle were saying
to me
but Glasgow is closer to us than
Westminster is and Westminster feels
very if different very you know far away
very distant and doesn't really
understand us so I think you know what
we need to do and the sort of underlying
principle of green political philosophy
is localism it's decisions being made
locally and that starts you at a level
even below Wales at the local community
level even local parish level and at the
moment we've got a system where power is
concentrated at the center at
Westminster and it allows sometimes some
power to trickle down and also of course
the money is concentrated there and the
money sometimes does or doesn't and
we've seen it increasingly cut off
trickle down we think you're I talked
before about the people's constitutional
convention one of the other things we'd
be saying to that would be the
power has to rest locally the money the
resources have to rest locally and that
starts at a very local level and only
gets referred up when it needs to be
okay we're going to move on to Fernandez
question hello I've been through my
experiences as a young person growing up
I've come across a lot of young people
have a lot of politicians who focus a
lot on issues and my main point is that
young people we want to feel inspired
want to feel like our leader not only
has a vision that lasts for years but a
vision that lasts long term some someone
that's able to move us and someone
that's able to shake us for example me
personally I've been inspired by youth
workers and young people that go to
youth Youth Council such as
Wolverhampton Youth Council twice a week
no pay and actually go to represent
their fellow citizens and as a result of
that I wanted to know what moves you
what inspires you as a person today I
think I'm going to go back to the to the
very start of my politics which is I
became a feminist at age five I didn't
actually know the word then but at age
five I was told because you're a girl
you're not allowed to have a bicycle and
at that point I thought that's not fair
or reasonable - because I'm a girl stop
me doing that and that sense of fairness
and the sense that so many people are
stopped from realizing their potential
doing what they want to do because of
unfair rules society putting
restrictions on them yeah that to me is
what kind of drives me in the sense of I
want everyone to have a chance for a
decent quality of life nobody if you're
if you're thinking about next week I
might have to go to the food bank or
next week I can't pay the rent you can't
live your life to the fool you can't go
out and do things with energy and
enthusiasm if that worry is there in
your head so we need to give everyone a
sense of security and stability so they
can then go and do whatever it is they
want with their life and not put
barriers in their way because of some
kind of artificial restriction and I do
now get round London by bicycle follow
up on sort of a personal question -
nothing
a question just behind the front so you
spoken about sexism so I was just
wondering what you would do if elected
to encourage young girls and women to
want to be politicians because there is
a large under-representation of women in
Parliament very much so it's absolutely
a disgrace that I need 23% of empathy is
a female and in the Green Party we're
aiming to have 50% of our female
candidates being female I don't think
we're quite going to get there but we're
aiming and if any of you are interested
there are still slots available but I
think you know what we need to do is
also change politics because if you look
at Prime Minister's Questions and that
RG bhaji yelling across the paper the
chamber you know making all kind of
noises chicken noises I don't think
that's the kind of quality of debate
that most people sort of ten-year-olds
in the playground would be a bit
embarrassed by so we really need to try
and you know making politics about
issues about ideas about inspiration
that you were talking about and not
about trying to score some points off
the other person in a kind of narrow
kind of way but it's not about the issue
but just because who I got I got a joke
Ian and my Drake was better than his
joke yeah but this question follows on
from that quite nicely and because there
are 650 and peas as far as my research
goes and 27 of them I think from ethnic
minorities just over 100 I think are
women how we are going to achieve true
representation unless we make voting
compulsory compulsory voting I think the
problem is that turns the problem around
the wrong way it suggests that voters
are the problem and I think actually
politics is the problem and so it's up
to the property shion's
to make politics is exciting and
evolving and make it feel like it's
worth voting rather than just making
people sort of trudge down and go yeah
I've done that right I'm not going to
get fine the pressure the focus should
be on the politicians not on the voters
let's move on to a question from social
media
from sally roberts how do you plan to
control immigration and those who claim
benefits for children which you do not
live in the UK okay well to start off
with I really want to lay it very
clearly on the table that I think we've
seen a hideous damaging divisive debate
on immigration and we need to stop
blaming immigrants for a whole range and
the thing is I mean we're standing now
in Hoban and some bankers to see that
I'm standing in and when I knock on
doors around here a lot of people say to
me oh I'm concerned about immigration
and I say what do you really mean by
that and what they usually say is one of
three things I'm concerned about low
wages I'm concerned about housing all
the issues we've been talking about and
I'm concerned about crowded schools and
hospitals and the thing is all of those
things are actually caused not by
immigrants but by failures of government
policy we have a low wage economy
because we have a minimum wage that's
too low and it adequately enforced we
have housing problems for all the
reasons I've talked about we have
crowded schools and hospitals partly
because of a failure to invest in terms
of the NHS because we've got the
disastrous privatization it's expensive
and reorganizations that have taken up
huge amounts of resources and then we've
got schools which I'll really say just
Michael Gove well I think that's all
we've got time for with Natalie Bennett
right now we've heard a lot we've heard
about rude words on ballots we've heard
about banning internships we've heard
about five-year-old feminism
well feminism for a five-year-old I
think but thank you for addressing the
questions from this audience and later
we'll be joined by the other political
leaders including the Labour Party and
the Lib Dems if you still have questions
for Miss Bennett
she'll be answering those in a live
facebook Q&A as soon as she comes off
set
we have full analysis coming up and you
can join the debate on social media just
use the hashtag ask the leaders that's
all for now
you